there are hundreds of villages like
these along the front line on the
Ukrainian controlled side
and what's increasingly worrying the
amount of civilians that are still here
as we understand this evacuation
continues in a separatist-controlled
areas
what is increasingly worrying also is
that in villages like these there are
also a lot of Ukrainian military and
we've been speaking to some of the
civilians here about their fears
soldiers stay in what were once private
homes
military vehicles passed by
Italia runs the village shop she has
little hope a peaceful solution to the
crisis can be found
the military's been here for eight years
but we all feel like targets of course
the military in the village makes the
risk greater I'm afraid to even think
about an evacuation if I would have to
leave my home suddenly with a bag of
documents who should not attending the
security conference in Munich suggests
he doesn't want a peaceful solution
most of the families of those buried in
the graveyard have left the village
people tell us the shelling in the area
and the last couple of days has been the
worst in years
it's very frightening I felt the fear
rising up through me when the shelling
started we've been here since the
beginning of the war but where can we go
and who can help us we heard about the
evacuation on the other side and it's
not a good sign there is no good that
will come out of this it's mainly the
elderly left here now they say the
shelling has been worse at night people
in villages like this one close to the
front line are afraid they are aware of
what the russian-backed separatists on
their side of the front line are now
calling a mass evacuation of civilians
and they are asking what about our
safety too Charles Stratford Al Jazeera
eastern Ukraine